[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est l'un des visages et
l'une des grandes voix du rugby français
et il tient ce rôle avec passion il est
même par fois surnommé le poète de
l'Ovalie il manie les mots aussi bien
que le ballon le rugby il le décrit il
l'interprète il le vit il le chante
quand certains y voi un sport de brut
lui vous le rend délicat humain
collectif lui vous parle d'aventure
humaine de cohésion de groupe d'unité
dans la diversité d'ailleurs c'est le
mot équipe qu'il a choisi de défendre
dans le livre de Philippe spanguero au
cœur de l'ovaliie un groupe d'humains
qui s'agrège avec amour autour d'un
projet commun écrit-il le rugby sport
rempli de belles valeurs de belles
personnes chéri par quelques millions de
téléspectateurs chaque semaine et
pourtant pratiqué par quelques centaines
de milliers seulement 300000 licenciés
quand le football en compte plus de 2
millions le tennis plus d'un million
pourquoi le rugby touche-t-il encore peu
de jeunes pourquoi même lorsque le 15 de
France brille en compétition le rugby
reste-t-il le sport d'une région d'une
culture une pratique un peu
confidentielle posons-lui toutes ces
questions bienvenu dans un m un regard
bienvenue à vous Daniel Herero merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
Sénat au D Tournon je le disais le rugby
n'est qu'à la 10è place des sports
pratiqués en France derrière le foot
évidemment ça je l'ai dit mais aussi
derrière l'équitation derrière la
natation derrière le canoï kayak il y a
un vrai contraste entre la médiatisation
de ce sport et le nombre de licenciés
comment vous l'expliquez vous c'est pas
si facile Rebecca le le jeu de Rubby on
sent que sur le territoire national il a
un rayonnement que son ronement est allé
croissant créchin dans les 20 30
dernières années ou 40 même et que il
est en il est en développement mais il
est en stagnation sur le nombre de
licenciés le nombre des clubs a augmenté
il est quand même assez conséquent
300000 licenciés c'est pas rien tu vois
sur le terrain ça teste quand même un
une affection 2 une polarité éducative
le jeu il a il a un
une un accueil une écoute dans la frange
jeune les clubs sont sont plutôt riches
les écoles de Rubby dans les sont plutôt
riches l'équipe nationale avec des haut
et des bas le sort d'une dizaine
d'années j'allais dire de de pénibilité
de difficulté de peu d'expression de
joie et de talent tu vois de panache tel
que que la culture française l'IM dans
les deux trois dernières années elle a
retrouver du lustre dans les temps
récents est même en appétit pour la CR
de gloire tu vois nous savons que à
moyen terme il y a il y a le pétillant
de de du grand rendez-vous mondial qu'on
appelle la Coupe du Monde euh assez
difficile à dire moi je pense que la
croissance est incontestable je pense
aussi que les qualités du jeu ou les
caractéristiques du jeu c'est un jeu
rude c'est un jeu évidemment aujourd'hui
tout asimute don les règles sont très
compliquées aussi pas tant que ça si on
regarde bien de fait il y en a trois ou
quatre qui sont totalement essentiels
pour que quelconque personne puisse le
lire à 0% la bas on la comprend mais ça
reste plus compliqué que une partie de
football quoi oui alors là il faut dire
que c'est une simplicité au limite du
ouais au limite de l'équivoque qui tu
vois tu dis quand même à ce point mais
non le jeu de Rubby a trois ou quatre
règles qui sont essentielles pour
comprendre l'esprit pour ne pas dire
l'âme tu vois le jeu il concentre autour
de deux ou trois trucs le grand groupe
le solidaire le partage le rude du monde
c'est autour de ça que tu vois et après
il y a une multitude tu vois il y a plus
de 120 règles qui sont venus
s'additionner comme ça mais qui de fait
ne ne transforme pas le sens base du jeu
tu peux regarder un match de Ruby il y a
sans règles que tu comprends pas c'est
pas bien grave si que comprend le sens
de l'affrontement du groupe et des
solidarité mais c'est aussi le un sport
qui reste cantonné à certaines régions
de France qui n'est pas partout qui ne
rayonne pas partout ne prends pas Brage
Rebecca mais il y a un vieux ponif qui
fait que cette pratique apportée par les
Anglais inventée par les Anglais au 19e
siècle elle s'installe sur la terre Sud
de France par l'intermédiaire autour de
Bordeaux puis ça rentre un peu sur le
Grand Sud le Grand Sud-Est le Grand
Sud-Ouest pardon pour l'essentiel de
fait non très vite il se développe dans
toutes ces zones là du Pays-Basque au
Pays Catalan tu vois en passant vers le
centre- France le massif tout ça é très
très ovale mais la vallée du rô l' aussi
historiquement et même et même la
Provence moi je suis issu tout longon tu
vois il y a un club centenaire il reste
que l'image là c'est le plus fertile le
plus fécond le plus abondant le plus
festoyant le plus peut-être même
rudoyant le plus authentiquement terroir
c'est dans le grand sud le Grand
Sud-Ouest de de la France un événement
comme le Mondial j'imagine va créer des
vocations peut être un trempelin vous le
voyez comme ça euh je je le sens je le
ressens je le trouve un peu forcé par
exemple peut-être mais tu étais tout
petite to
rebea en 2007 il y a la Coupe du Monde
de Ruby qui a eu lieu en France en 2007
ça monte pas à des lustres tu vois ça
fait quand même que 18 ans
oua et et de fait la France aant été
dans cette compétition là de 2007
relativement piteuse peu flamboyante
déclenche un peu de de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler d'appétit d'écoute d'éveil et
même d'attirance vois d'empathie
quasiment
non ça ve pas générer des grande
turbulence celle-là là qui s'annonce là
on est à une encablure tu vois ou là il
y a quelque chose là ça pétit ça pétit
en talent ça pétit en comportement ça
pétit he c'est difficile à dire je pas
dire tu vois un en cœur de France h mais
cœur de France ça veut dire c'est assez
joyeux la voy aller loin cette équipe
nationale ou pas l'équipe nationale elle
a tous les attribut alors après tu tu tu
peux pas ignorer le sport a un champ
d'indécision c'est conséquent hein et
maintenant ça fluctue vite d'un jour à
l'autre d'un match à l'autre parce que
c'est très tributaire de l'aventure de
l'équipe et une équipe une seule parole
tueuse dans ce collectif là peut abîmer
un collectif qui a mis 7 ou 8 ans à se à
se construire à s'élaborer tu vois à se
constituer quoi maintenant quand même
quasiment tous les tous les paramètres
sont réunis c'est sur sur la terre de
France où il y a un amour débordant un
amour débordant tu sais j'allais dire le
peuple le peuple de dovali peut-être le
rubis de France tu vois non mais mais
enfin quand même il y a il y a dans le
dans dans le champ social français
aujourd'hui une espèce de considération
d'affection pour le pour le rubbi
français et cette affection all est sur
ah il y a des talents il y a des enfants
du pays il y a il y a un volume de jeu
il y a en même temps ce qui est une des
caractéristiques essentielles de
l'affection que l'on peut porter à ce
jeu il y a grande humilité rugby vous
êtes né dedans he votre père était un
bon joueur votre mère vous emmenait le
voir tous les dimanches après-midi il
jouait pour le club de la scinene surmer
dans le Var vous entendiez les adultes
autour de vous dire Herero il est
vaillant et puis vos trois frères
jouaient aussi dont un à très haut
niveau je crois le ballon devient très
vite votre meilleure amie vous dites je
jouais à la balle dès que je pouvais il
n'y avait pas de livre pas de musique
pas de radio chez nous tous ces champs-l
étaient obstrué la balle avec laquelle
je m'amusais dans la rue était tout
finalement le chemin était tout tracé
non vous n'aviez pas vraiment le choix
alors il m'arrive de de m'interroger sur
est-ce que j'ai pas eu un guidage
familial tu vois une orientation ou
alors si on est du domaine de
l'orientation il y a pas faute tu vois
si on est domaine de l'oppression de la
tu vois de l'obligatoire de l' tu vois
si on te conditionne dans le choix de
ton trajet il y a une suspiciion
considérable et probablement un désastre
à venir tu vois non moi le milieu était
un Bibé d'ovallie mais mon père était
mon père aimait les matchs et ma mère
aimait les mots moi mon père il aimait
le R donc j'allais voir jouer mon père
et c'est vrai qu' avoir entendu alors
que dans le milieu dans lequel nous nous
déployons on avait pas de de de de chant
de de haute confiance en nous quoi avoir
entendu dans ma toute petite enfant et
rérot il est vaillant je percevais ça
comme étant commeant une pas une
flatterie mais oh tu vois une
considération humaine mon père il
faisait partie des grands s' il était
vaillant tu vois voilà voilà ensuite on
m'a déposé quand même assez tôt par par
le milieu familial et assez vite quand
même là 8 9 10 ans on m'a déposé un peu
che dire sur le le Paris du temple on
m'a mis devant le stade on m'a tu vois
on m a accompagné je n'ai jamais senti
que on m'a pas tiré les oreilles et on
m'y a pas on m'y a pas mis on m'a
accompagné vers une une hypothétique
champ de plaisir et de bonheur pas
forcément sur une route décisive ouais
le programme est plutôt sympa et à la
lueur de celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui
quel conseil donneriez-vous au petit
garçons que vous étiez qu'est-ce que
vous lui diriez avant qu'il ne se lance
dans la vie ah alors là là ça serait un
peu plus délicat parce que j'auris le
goû de l'accompagner j'aurais pas le
goût de lui tirer les oreilles comme tu
l'auras compris j'aurais le goût de lui
de lui souffler dans dans dans dans dans
j' dire presque dans le dos plus que de
le prendre par la main
quoi la
préoccupation prioritaire pour moi
serait il faut que je trouve ce qu'il
aime tu vois il faut que je trouve il
faut que moi qui l'accompagne qui suis
prof qui suis enseignant qui suis
peut-être entraîneur et qui suis en même
temps peut-être père en tu que je trouve
là où ça lui va au cœur parce que je
sais je sais comme une conviction
éperdue que si on l'accompagne vers ceux
qu' l'aiment il y a des chances qu'il
soi heureux voilà et qu' réussisse j'ai
un document à vous proposé il s'agit
d'un document proposé par les Archives
nationales qui sont nos partenaires dans
cette émission je vais vous lire hein le
document pour pour ceux qui nous
écoutent aussi il s'agit du contte-rendu
technique de maintien de l'ordre des CRS
à l'occasion de la finale du championnat
de France de rugby 1968 entre le FC
lourd et le RC Toulon à Toulouse
remporté par lourd un match pour lequel
je crois vous n'êtes pas sélectionné par
votre propre frère parce que vous vous
êtes un peu laissé embarquer par les
manif de 68 et lors de ce match il est
écrit sur ce document que vers la fin de
la deuxème mi-temps une cinquantaine de
jeunes gens supporters de l'équipe du
RCT avaient réussi à enjamber les
barrières mobiles et qu'au cours des
prolongations quelques jeunes ont envahi
le terrain avec des banderoles pendant
ce match vous étiez où vous vous en
souvenez ou pas pas du côté de ceux qui
perturbai un peu le ouou oh non j'aurais
pu à la limite être sur le terrain
j'aurais même dû je pense que j'avais
fait tous les matchs de l'année mais
jusqu'à la demi-finale tu vois mais
après les événements de Mai commencent
68 à s'enflamme moi j'ai 20 ans à ce
moment-là je me mets un peu dans la
turbulence je suis pas un rebel la
légende dit que vous avez caayassé des
des voitures de force V légende la
légende caayassé je ne sais guerre mais
je me suis mis en face j'avais pas
l'impression que j'étais à côté j'étais
pas non j'étais pas dans la turbulence
mortifère moi j'étais dans dans dans la
la seule expression de ma nature tu vois
et de ma jovialité voilà non je j'ai pas
le souvenir d'avoir été dans dans dans
dans dans la vulgaritéaine non mais
alors après sur le terrain alors
effectivement j'aurais pu être sur le
terrain j'aurais pu être dans la tribune
en l'occurrence là je ne joue pas parce
que parce que ça fait de mois que je
m'entraîne pas donc la finale est et
bien bien après le fait que ce soit mon
Franin qui a le pouvoir de décision
ouais non c'est pas cétait pas
diabolique je sais que j'avais fait 2
ans de manifestation en 2 mois de
manifestation et que je m'étais
moyennement entraîner donc j'avis as
quand même laissé des traces en vous
cette décision de votre frère oui
fatalement fatalement tu vois il y a
mais mais aucune trace d'amère
d'amertumeement non non
ça va la vie assez loin il avait
objectivement raison quoi non il avait
totalement
tort mais en même temps même temps il
aurait sendu du voir que même si j'avais
perdu un peu de mes attributs physiques
ma ma compétence technique était
largement suffisante pour que je joue la
finale mais non j'ai pas non non j'ai
j'ai pas de sur sur ces chant de sur ce
sujet là pardon j'ai pas d'amertum par
contre effectivement il y a des
turbulences j'aurais pu être dans b
aussi descendre j'aurais pu peut-être he
quandême alors là il y a des turbulences
qui sont un peu suspectes parce que
elles sont liées à l'événement elles
sont liées en même temps à tout long de
ce temps-là dans son Ruby en
l'occurrence génère des supporters un
peu enflammés un peu turbulents euh tu
vois il y a quand même quelque chose
autour de il y a a la permanence d'une
de de d'une d'une manière d'être un peu
un peu parano quoi on ne nous aime pas
Toulon tu vois euh le post 68 ans enfin
juste la période hein fait qu'il y a
quelques turbulen mais enfin bon euh ell
font elles ont donné l'occasion quand
même de faire que 40 ans après ou 50 ans
après par
reparle un match de rub vous avez dit je
n'étais pas un maoïste sauvageon mais
totalement de gauche et sensible à
l'injustice sociale ma famille était
communiste mon mon père vendait l'humain
parce que vous avez quand même été
politisé tout au long de votre vie de
votre carrière certains l'ont peut-être
oublié mais en 97 vous publiez aussi un
livre très explicite petites histoires
raconté un jeune du Front national c'est
un message d'espoir que vous adressez à
la jeunesse pour la dissuader de voter
pour le Front national à ce moment-là
vous êtes très marqué par les élections
municipales je crois de 95 lors
desquelles Toulon est passé entre les
mains du FN en l'occurrence entre celle
de Jean-Marie Le Chevalier et
aujourd'hui la lueur de ce que vous avez
écrit et de la façon dont vous étiez
politisé qu'est-ce que vous avez envie
de lui dire à cette jeunesse qui
aujourd'hui vote en majorité Front
national alors ça je ne sais pas que la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui vote en majorité
Front national je me met un peu 25 34
pour voà on pour dire sur les 18 25 ans
je suis un peu moins formé et sur les
ouais le jeune débutant dans la vie dans
la vie d'adulte je dirais alors moi le
souvenir que j'ai c'est que la famille
elle est pas politisée elle est elle est
d'extraction modeste c'est des gens de
peu les miens quoi tu vois et mon père
il est petit ouvrier et dans le chantier
il est dans les chantiers naval de la
scène il est il a un petit engagement
militant ilvant Luma il est coco tu vois
voilà ça baigne un peu ça baigne l'idée
quand même que le pauvre a le droit à la
parole presque tu vois que le pauv a
droit à la ré le pauvre a droit à la
répartition des biens bon que le PA le
pauvre a aussi droit à à dire ce qu'il
pense et à me tendre la main en disant
si je suis un peu moins pauvre c'est pas
plus mal quoi tu vois et s'il est très
très riches sont un peu moins riches
c'est pas plus nombre voilà gross modo
je peigne que là-dedans tu vois enfin
quand même mon père avu mal le dimanche
au marché bon ça malgré tout quoi tu
vois et aujourd'hui encore je suis je
sais pas comment on pourrait dire mais
vice-président dans la société des amis
du journal d'humit tu vois bon ben pour
dire bon je reste alors que de gauche
alors incontestable tu vois social total
pr prês encore à toute à toutes les
luttes prê prê ouais prê à toutes les
Lutes oui toutes les Lutes ouais ouais
ouis toutes les luttes ma chemise
ouverte en avant sur il faut quand même
que que que l'on je sais pas que que
l'on améliore dans notre société le sort
de ceux qui l'ont dur voilà pas mes
grands-parents étaient des immigrés
espag dites-vous d'extraction misérable
illétré ils ont traversé les Pyrénées
pour ne pas mourir de faim ont travaillé
de ferme en ferme et sont morts en
parlant espagnol sans jamais avoir pris
la nationalité française ça vient de là
tout ce que vous nous dites aujourd'hui
il est difficile de savoir le poids de
tes gênes de fait tu peux te l'analyser
quoi tu vois moi mes grands-parents sont
de l'exile mes grands-parents tu vois
ils viennent d'Espagne dans l'Espagne de
la misère du début du 20e siècle ils
franchissent les Pyrénées ils ont jamais
les papier on les ramène ils sont
attrapé on le ramène deux fois mon
grand-père on le
ramène un espagnol tu vois on on le
rejette du territoire français mes
parents naissent sur le territoire de
France mais ils sont ils sont espagnols
à leur naissance mon père est natural
mon père et ma mère naturalisé à 18 ans
B je le c'est pas que je le traîne tu
vois je je me le porte sans aucun doute
un peu j'ai j'ai j'ai une autre
considération du déplacement de la
rencontre de l'autre de lailleurme et
une vraie curiosité pour l'étranger oui
voilà ouis plus que plus que la la la la
la peur la peur désastreuse de l'exil tu
vois c je l'ai pas trop ce qui
caractérise le rugby ce sont je l'ai dit
hein les belles valeurs dont je parlais
en introduction et qui sont réunis dans
ce livre porté par Philippe panguero au
cœur de l'ovaliy 15 personnalités du
rugby dont vous mais aussi Vincent cler
Thierry du sauttoir Walter spanguero
parl rugby au travers de 150 mots
expression et vous vous avez choisi le
mot équipe l'équipe et vous écrivez je
n'entendais le mot équipe que dans mon
club ou dans mes sélections
exclusivement dans le monde du sport et
dans son champ lexical limité jamais
ailleurs ni à l'école ni à la télé ni ni
à l'église les valeurs de solidarité et
de fraternité que certains appellent les
valeurs de l'Ovalie manquent un peu
ailleurs
ah tu veux le mot le mot d'équipe qui
qui semble retranscrire quand même une
aventure collective ou des gens en
groupe déjens tu vois ont des liens un
peu originaux on définit pas bien mais
on voit bien que c'est pas une famille
que c'est pas un clan que c'est pas une
palanquée une meut une orde tu vois une
tribu voz le mot équipe moi je l'ai
beaucoup entendu mon père travaillé dans
au chantier naval il il avait un chef
d'équipe c'était dans le monde du
travail mais pas beaucoup après je l'ai
entendu que dans le monde du sport et
aujourd'hui je vois bien qu'il inonde
qu'il a qu' qui baignne comme une espèce
de noblesse des choses comme si si tu
rentres dans la dimension de l'équipe tu
rentres dans la dimension des des des
liens qui qui accroche qui qui qui
solidarise le monde tu rentres dans
quelque chose qui fait qui fait évoluer
quoi comme si le terme d'équipe porter
l'idée quand on est ensemble ma foi
pourquoi pas et si en même temps
ensemble ça ça change alors ça peut
enrichir VO et et moi ça ligne de vie
ligne de vie je n'ai la balle était ma
compagne parce que avec elle je je
cheminé vous savez ces belles valeurs
dont je parle dans le dans le rugby
souvent ça agace aussi les supporters de
football qui ont l'impression il y a une
espèce de petite rivalité entre le monde
du rugby et le monde du foot le monde du
foot disant enfin ça va les belles
valeurs ne sont pas que dans le monde du
rugby vous la sentez cette petite
rivalité qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre
au les belles valeurs ne concernent que
le rugby ou il y en a ailleurs dans la
pratique Corp
sportive tu vois réglementer physique
il y a des sports collec le foot le
basket ou tu t'aperçois que aucun ne
valorise à ce point le tas le grand
groupe la fusion le partage le r aucun
tous sont dans quand même des pratiques
de distance nos amis footballur c'est
mes frères de fait non mais ce sont nos
frères il y a des petites impertinences
serait-il titulaire quand même d'une
belle âme tu vois des fois on
s'interroge alors qu'on aurait presque
la sensation malgré tout que tu vienses
dans le champ du rubbi tu es titulaire
obligatoire d'une âme respect able et
social obligatoire il y a pas d'autre
hypothèse dans nos amis footbalurs tu as
la sensation que le narcissisme est plus
aiguisé tu vois la bourseou Flure de leg
est plus éminente le jeu n'est qu'un jeu
de duel chacun quand tuas la balle éit
tout seul avec un collègue en face qui
défend et quand toi tu défends c'est tu
vas essayer c'est que des duels duel ça
veut dire deux mais on joue ensemble
quand tu as toujours la sensation que
dans un jeu comme le football et même
dans les autres jeux de pratique
collective le 1 est un peu dominant sur
le groupe tu as la certitude que dans le
jeu de Ruby le groupe est toujours
dominant sur le voilà intéressant alors
je vais peut-être un peu faire
l'arabageois mais le rugby n'est n'est
pas un monde idéal on nous trouve on y
trouve aussi des dérives de la violence
des choses à corriger peut-être
avez-vous lu ce livre de Philippe
Chauvin rugby mourir fait partie du jeu
le combat d'un père uillé il a perdu son
fils mort à la suite d'un double
plaquage d'une très grande violence le
gamin avait 18 ans et son père demande
aujourd'hui que l'on revoit les règles
du du rugby comment vous regardez
ça cette pratique elle a elle a des
traits identitaires qui en font sa
richesse considérable et qui en font un
potentiel complexe à gérer quoi le jeu
de Ruby c'est un jeu on est nombreux
rien que fait mais ça a évolué ça ça a
changé dans le tempsoui oui
incontestablement la douleur du PER tu
vois le départ vers les étoiles de ce
Mino là c'est c'est un drame qui nous
impact mais de façon diabolique tu vois
à l'évidence grosso modo dans un contact
en r il y en a beaucoup r le Rubby c'est
un jeu de chute et de choc donc donc
c'est inhérant et donc tu vas rencontrer
tu vas rencontrer est-ce que ces
contacts ne se sont pas forcer aggraver
avec le temps alors le professionnalisme
depuis une vingtaine d'années les les
les joueurs pro tu es plus là pour
passer une belle jeunesse tu es là pour
réussir ta vie tu t'entraînes beaucoup
tu doubles ton volume tu mets les colers
à l'horizontal tu as la gaillardise qui
va qui laisserait même penser que
l'excès de gaillardise commence à
limiter un peu l'excès de pensé tu vois
il faut faire un peu un peu attention à
ce monde là quoi le jeu de Rubby il est
devenu c'est historiquement un jeu très
dur maintenant c'est un jeu
régulièrement très dur moi par exemple
je plaquais deux ou trois fois par match
si je tombais deux ou trois fois par
match ça pouvoir me faire mal
aujourd'hui il tombe 25 30 fois 35 fois
les chocs sont plus nombreux donc pour
vous il y a pas à changer les règles les
règles ont changé le alors bizarrement
c'est une de ses beautés une de ses
douleurs aussi c'est c'est une
complainte au monde le jour de Ruby
toutes les années il y a deux ou trois
règles depuis 100 ans hein donc il y a
un nombre considérable de règ et et
c'est de règles et c'est les règles ont
toujours deux missions la protection de
l'homme et la enfin du joueur pardon et
la protection de la balleis si tu
touffes la balle en rubis vite vite des
règles sont arrivées pour laisse la
vivre pour qu'on puisse jouer et si tu
es en danger et si tu mets l'homme
délibérément enang B vite vite on
s'aperçoit que les chocs sont devenus de
plus en plus dur et à la sortie à la
sortie alors chaque année tu as plus le
droit de de plaquer avec ton bras sur le
cou de l'autre tu as plus le droit
d'intervenir sur la visage tu as plus le
droit tu vois tu as plus le droit de le
renverser par terre et de donc a une
remise en question complète il y a une
peur bleue il y a une peur bleue que que
cette cette douleur potentielle elle
devienne dominante jusqu'à jusqu'à mais
il y a pris à payer de sûr hein de sûr
il y a pris à payer il nous reste à
espérer que l'éducation elle elle ne
touche pas tellement les zones de
dangérosité elle touche que il faut que
tu te décentres sur l'idée que toute
forme de combat et de contact n'est pas
destructrice mais qu'elle est qu'une
hypothèse pour arrêter l'adversaire tu
vois ça le jour où je rentre sur un
terrain pour te faire à la misère c'est
que déjà il y a un problème c'est que
déjà il y a un problème j'ai des photos
à vous
montrer la première la voici c'est une
photo du 15 de France féminin les
sélections nationales en rugby à 15
féminin existe depuis les années 80
première Coupe du monde en 91 la France
est 3e le rugby féminin commence tout
juste à s'installer dans le cœur des
Français est-ce qu'il est installé dans
le vôtre oh mais plus que ça ah non je
suis militant de la première heure moi
ah
ouais
68 si tu te rappelles pas légitimement
tu tu as mémoire chez trè Grands Anciens
de ce que ça pu ça laisse germer oh il y
a la main tendue à tous dans la liberté
d'être masculin comme féminin ce S c'est
c'est c'est c'est une gloire
considérable sur le bonheur des gens
quel qu'il soit franchement après bon il
y a tout ces lourdeur et c'est pas
lourdi mais les pratiques sportives
masculines pour l'essentiel à plus forte
raison les rudes sont catalogués dans le
clan des macho des fil misogyes des
phalocrates et et les filles qui ne
peuvent pas rentrer en dans dans la
l'organisation fédérale quoi tu vois cré
en 68 710 et moi je mets un peu mon OBO
ou tout au moins mon soutien que je suis
déjà un peu un peu un joueur pertorier
sur elle elle crée la Fédération non pas
la Fédération l'Association française de
Rubby féminin ça va aller lentement mais
sûrement mais lentement hein jusqu'à
aujourd'hui être acté c'est
acté l'égalité elle y est de fait dans
le sens moral elle y est pas encore dans
les réalités les filles ne gagnent pas
l'argent mais elle est dans votre esprit
déjà en tout cas ah totalement
totalement et tu veux que je te dise he
j'ai la sensation qu'elle est dans
l'esprit du monde nooval une deuxème et
dernière photo c'est une une du JDD
alors le titre est un peu prétexte mais
c'est aussi un peu votre journal votre
comm sudadio vous y avez écrit des
chroniques les journalistes ont ét en
grève après la nomination deoffro le
jeune à la direction du journal
considéré comme étant proche de
l'extrême droite comme vous êtes un peu
politisé vous n'hésitez pas à parler
politique j'ai envie de vous demander si
vous êtes solidaire du mouvement de la
rédaction de du JDD qui ne veut pas de
cette direction d'extrême droite très
honnêtement je répondrai oui sans sans
hésitation dire que le journal du GIM
j'ai eu le
privilège de le côtoyer j'ai écrit une
chronique R hier pendant 25 ans donc
c'est assez conséquent non je l'avais
dans mon cœur et je l'ai toujours
d'ailleurs et et et voir la turbulence
ça bouge ça bouge pourquoi on on on
institutionnalise à la direction de
l'établissement une personnalité
incontestable tu vois titulaire d'un
potentiel de réflexion incontestable
aussi c'est pas un omie trouvé dans la
rue à la sortie il a en même temps il
affirme aujourd'hui descidé que moi je
mettrai dans le clan des ségrégatifs des
des des des ouvertures sociales limitées
avec avec des des considérations des
considérations politiques que je trouve
incontestablement de de d'une limite
humaniste qui me qui me qui me choque
quoi voilà à partir de là à partir de là
ouais non c'est pas ta place mec c'est
pas ta place va tes collègues va AC tes
collègues va où où où là où les tiens
chantent c'est le le le chant que toi tu
portes bon après moi je me mettrai en
face s'il faut un jour être en rébellion
quoi tu vois mais par contre dans une
institution comme celle-là ouverte au
monde ce journal il a il avait quand
même cette il a toujours espèce de de de
de liberté de de butiner tu vois comme
ça quotidiennement la diversité du monde
en même temps il a une Hare une hautre
considération des choses de la culture
de la culture populaire à plus forte
raison bon non voilà moi je dirais il
faut que tu disposes une dernière
question qui est en lien avec le lieu
dans lequel nous sommes nous sommes
entourés de quatre statut qui représente
chacune une vertu il y a ici la sagesse
la prudence la justice et l'éloquence
laquelle de ces vertus vous parle le
plus ou vous caractérise vous ah tu vois
le le évidemment la justice quand même
ça une manière d'être au monde une loi
de fond quand même mais enfin enfin j'ai
j'ai tellement de de de de de de de de
d'angoisse personnelle sur son évolution
sur tu vois sur sa elle fait partie des
choses que j'aime et sur lequell le
combat est permanent euh sur sur la S ah
non la sagesse
non c'est pas vous humaine non je pense
je pense non anomalie je pense erreur
erreur non erreur si on considère que ça
burine le monde que ça le met dans des
dans des limitations ça le met dans des
hauteurs de pensées ça le met dans des
limitations d'être donc je suis pas
cette route donc la justice non
l'éloquence l'éloquence ah ouais ah
ouais franchement d'accord non
franchement ok mais on a compris
pourquoi vous avez parlé des mots c'est
par ta présence moi je pense que tu
enseigne autant ce que tu es que ce que
tu sais tu vois y compris dans ton
travail mais en même temps je pense
essentiellement quand même que le fait
que l'on a envie de te suivre de
t'écouter ou c'est parce que tu nous le
formules bien tu vois ouis je pense je
pense que quand même ceux qui dirigent
le monde c'est ceux qui se mettent
devant et qui l'explique ou qui le
montre ou qui en avançant font en sorte
que le sens que porte les choses soit
clairement transmis au monde alors ce
sera l'éloquence merci merci infiniment
d'avoir été notre invité ici au Dom
tourn CNA merci d'avoir joué le jeu de
toutes ces questions et de tous ces
rituels merci beaucoup et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
à très vite sur public Sena
[Musique]
merci